Earlier today,
Conrad Black wrote an article in
Canada's National Post and the article
was called Jordan Peterson speaks,
for those of us who refused to follow
the great liberal deathwish.
Now,
for those of you who don't know who
conrad black is,
I'll read you a little bit from his
wikipedia profile.
Conrad Moffat.
Black Baron black of cross harbor was
born on the 25th of August,
1944.
He's a Canadian born British,
former newspaper publisher and author.
He's a non affiliated life peer,
black controlled Holland,
your international once the world's
third largest English language newspaper
Empire,
which published the Daily Telegraph in
the UK,
the Chicago Sun Times in the US and the
Jerusalem Post Israel as well as in the
National Post,
the newspaper that he published this
article in in Canada and hundreds of
community newspapers in North America.
I'd like to start this by thinking
lord black for his support.
But I would also like to point out that
despite his supportive stance,
um,
there are things that are important that
he didn't get right.
And I think it's reasonable to draw
people's attention to them.
So the first thing I'm going to do is
just read what he wrote and then I'm
going to comment on it a little bit
and I'm going to do so in a manner that
I hope does indicate that I do
appreciate his support and I'm not
trying to be,
um,
pr frivolously critical in any sense.
And then I want to read a response that
a lawyer has prepared as well,
just so that you understand all of you
who are listening understand this a
little bit more clearly.
Conrad Black Rights.
I have just endured the sobering
experience of watching the always very
intelligent and professional Steve Pakan
chair a panel about the transgender
controversy that centers on University
of Toronto.
Professor Dr Jordan Peterson.
That was the.
I had an appearance on TV,
was the agenda with Steve Pakan a couple
of weeks ago where the Pronoun issue was
discussed.
Lack states.
I had vaguely followed the story as it
percolated up in the press,
much of the fraud things in which must
usually be taken lightly.
It was I fear a piercing glimpse into
what great and venerable statesmen of my
youth,
such as Winston Churchill,
Dwight Eisenhower,
Harry Truman and Louis St Laurent called
days that I shall not see.
I did not until now grasp the fine
balance between gratitude and
wistfulness in their invocation of that
phrase,
as a young person,
I thought at the license of the great to
engage in Histrionics and I now claim it
as the right of lesser yet aging people
such as myself,
black states for those who have sagely
duct or otherwise being spared exposure
to this controversy.
Dr Peterson rejects the right of his
students to require him to address them
if they are trans people,
I eat in some state of flux between the
male and female polls of gender
identification,
not their orientation,
whether they are homosexual,
heterosexual,
bisexual,
or asexual,
has nothing to do with it.
Otherwise then in a way that concerns
them to the cluster confines of being
male or female.
No.
See,
this is one of the things that's
interesting about,
about Mr. blocks
call them.
He obviously considers this issue of
sufficient importance to address it,
but there's an that he can't eliminate
completely from his mind the supposition
that this is absurd,
but it is observed in many ways,
but here's the mistake.
Just because something is absurd,
it doesn't mean it was trivial and I
think this is where Mr Black makes an
error in his column.
Yes,
it's absurd.
That's why he says that people have
sagely ducted or otherwise being spared
exposure to it because it's been a
ridiculous controversy and I think.
I think there's no question about that.
It's surreal.
I found the whole thing was surreal,
but you know,
back in the 19 thirties when the Nazis
first made their appearance on the
scene,
everyone thought they were observed to
and and concluded that that meant that
they were trivial and they were not
trivial despite their absurdity,
and this is not trivial despite its
absurdity.
In fact its absurdity.
I think in some sense points precisely
to the fact that it is anything but
trivial because something that is on the
surface of it so absurd is being made so
much is being made of it.
It's been classified if refuse,
we'll use pronouns,
for example,
is being classified as a hate crime
that's not trivial,
although it is observed
now
z for he and or she and Zack are in
place of his or him are the sticking
points,
but what is accumulating behind these
imbecilic distinctions is quite
sinister.
The tape,
Steve Pake and ran up Dr Peterson being
reviled and shouted down and physically
intimidated at the University of Toronto
was distressing and we may be on the
edge of a defining moment in our jolie
and progressive Canadian civilization.
Dr Peterson sees it as a matter of
freedom of expression and believes that
others do not have the authority to
require him to address them in a newly
hatched vocabulary devise to oppress the
gender binary conventional practice.
While his opponents profess to believe
that in refusing to do so,
he is committing a hate crime punishable
by human rights commissions or
tribunals.
These hurry headed monsters and black is
referring to the human rights tribunals,
who's agregious tryst trespasses on
freedom of expression in the name of
despotic.
Political correctness has been heroic.
They didn't successfully contested by my
friends Mark Stein and as relevant and
others does not prescribe imprisonment
under the articles invoked by Dr.
Peterson says assailant,
but if fine is possible,
yes,
and we might also point out that it's a
very large fine that is possible in New
York state,
for example,
failure to use the requisite pronouns
brings with it a maximum fine of
$250,000 in case Conrad goes on to say
as if to assure the least possibility of
a quiet end to this preposterous issue,
Dr Peterson has declared that he will
not pay a fine and if in prison for not
paying it would embark on a hunger
strike.
Now,
this is another place where black
confuses absurdity with triviality.
He believes that my response to this is
an overreaction and that's part of my
refusal to bring this preposterous issue
to a quiet end.
He's suggesting that I'm exaggerating
and that as a consequence,
he's implying that I'm at least in part,
responsible for blowing up something
that's merely observed into something.
I'm blowing up the importance of
something that's merely observed
anyways.
He says,
well,
my sympathies are with Dr Peterson.
This is an unjustified hypothetical
escalation.
So remember that he says this is an
unjustified hypothetical escalation if
it came to that,
the authorities would attach his bank
account or his income in to collect the
fine and Batman or rather than
imprisoning him and provoking a hunger
strike.
Yes.
Well,
we'll see about that.
Okay.
So the first thing that I want to tell
you,
listeners is,
here's,
here's the powers of the social justice
tribunals.
I pulled this from their own statement
about their power.
So this is one point six.
This is section one,
point six,
powers of the social justice tribunals
in irrelevant,
um,
Ontario legislative document one point
six.
You have to listen to this very
carefully.
The tribunal will determine how a matter
will be dealt with.
That's a matter brought before them,
say a matter of discrimination or
harassment defined by their policies,
their appalling policies and may use
procedures other than traditional
adjudicative or adversarial procedures.
Okay,
so I'm going to repeat that.
The tribunal will determine how a matter
will be dealt with and may use
procedures other than traditional
adjudicative or adversarial procedures.
Okay,
that's one point.
Six,
one point seven.
In order to provide for the fair just
and expeditious resolution of any matter
before it.
The tribunal may a limit the evidence or
submissions on any issue so you can
consider that for a while and I'm going
to skip to w take any other action that
the tribunal determines is appropriate.
Now you,
you've got that they've actually written
a clause into the policy documents that
describe their powers that states that
they can take any other action they
determine as appropriate.
Well then I would say that's gone beyond
absurd.
Um,
or I would say that's still observed,
but it's by no means trivial and my
sense that this is extraordinarily
dangerous legislation is correct.
Whereas dark Mr Block's insistence that
I'm exaggerating,
the seriousness of the situation is
incorrect.
Here's three point one,
three from the same document where a
party has been notified of a fair
hearing and fails to attend.
Tribunal may take any other action it
considers appropriate.
So that's a duplication of the previous
statement,
roughly speaking with,
um,
where the human rights tribunal takes to
itself the power to do whatever it wants
fundamentally.
Now,
here's some other things to consider.
Notice that these tribunals,
including the Ontario human rights
tribunals,
there's eight different tribunals.
They're called social justice tribunals.
Now,
that's not an accident.
Consider what that means.
The term social justice is a code for
political correctness and equity
oriented political philosophy.
People know that this is why the radical
left activists are parodied as social
justice warriors.
Now the social justice tribunals
operating in Ontario or quasi judicial
instantiations of the politically
correct authoritarian creed,
and they're designed by their designers
to operate outside of the normal
parameters of the law.
This is why they attribute to themselves
the powers to use quote procedures other
than traditional adjudicative or
adversarial procedures.
Think about that.
It means that the standard British
common law approach to the issues
brought before the tribunal can be
suspended.
Now,
why would they do that?
Well,
it's rooted in politically correct,
the underlying politically correct
Marxist and postmodernist philosophy.
You can consider it this way.
If the fundamental presupposition is
that the,
uh,
that,
that Canadian civilization as well as
Western civilization in general is a
corrupt patriarchy.
Then what's the problem with suspending
it's rules of procedure when you're
pursuing a justice the tire than
anything that's a represented inside
that tradition?
Well,
that's exactly what they've written into
the,
into the laws attributing to themselves
power so you can see,
you can think for yourself and decide
just exactly how dangerous that is.
Now,
back to black Dr Peterson's approach is
so inflexible and so entirely righteous
without much using the powerful weapon
of ridicule that is available to him.
He may not have tracked the full range
of support.
The virtue of his arguments and his
personal courage deserve so funny
sentence because I can't tell exactly
the terminology that my approach is so
inflexible that I may not attract the
full range of support.
The virtue of my arguments,
my personal courage deserve.
Um,
I don't really think that I'm being
reflected in flexible.
I'm merely refusing to use the language
that's made up by politically correct
radical left wing authoritarians.
And that's not inflexible.
It's reasonable.
Why would I use that language?
I don't agree with the philosophy.
I think the principles upon which it's
predicated are not only factually
incorrect,
scientifically incorrect,
but malevolently motivated and
extraordinarily dangerous.
That doesn't make me inflexible,
and so the terminology there is wrong.
It makes me committed to not using that
language,
but on the substance of the issue.
Lack continues.
He is of course correct.
We must always be wary of the majority
Darien tyranny,
which has preoccupied mini civil
libertarians,
including the principal authors of the
constitution of the United States,
especially James Madison and Alexander
Hamilton,
who agreed on little else about the
transgender community is less than one
percent of the population,
as I've written many times in many
contexts,
over many tiers rights do not exist only
for the numerous and a litmus test of
legitimacy of a society is it's
observance of the rights of minorities,
including especially minorities.
Have one.
The jurisprudence of all great
democratic nations is replete with
famous cases to this effect.
Captain Dreyfus,
Dr Samuel Mudd,
who was prosecuted for treating the
assassin of Abraham Lincoln.
Though there was no evidence that he was
involved in the plot and even the
British Archer Shia fair made famous in
the drama,
the winslow boy,
the Peterson affairs threatening to
cross the double white line.
All people must be treated with respect
equally,
but there are only two genders to sexist
are species and all other mammals are
gender binary.
While I would like to point out to Mr
Block that that's now illegal under bill
[inaudible] and its associated sister
legislation and that might be observed
as I mentioned before,
but it's not trivial idiocy written into
the law unfolds into the idiocy of
enforcement and obedience and that's not
trivial and as we will soon find out,
lot continues.
All people may state their sex and if
that is contrary to physical
appearances,
that remains the right,
but no individual or group has the right
to invent a new vocabulary and a new
cool co equal gender because of a state
of ambivalence or confusion about which
sex they are.
Yes,
Mr Black,
they do have that right and that's
precisely what bill see.
16 instantiates and it's already written
into the human rights codes,
human rights codes of the majority of
Canadian provinces.
It's also,
uh,
it's also an act of hate speech to
dispute it.
So individuals and groups have precisely
the right to invent new vocabularies and
not one but many co equal genders up to
70 in New York state for example,
black continues,
every legally competent individual has a
perfect and absolute right to declare
their sex,
but not to create a new legal status and
legally require the use of a new
vocabulary for those influx between the
only two sexes we have mercilessly
binary throw their finite number may be
well the same argument applies there.
They do have the right to create a new
legal status or many new legal statuses
and to legally require the use of a new
vocabulary that's already written into
the law that they have that right.
And I would say as well that,
uh,
Conrad blocks comments on that are also
now illegal.
The individuals in that condition may
change the registered sex each day if
they wish,
but not treat anyone who declines to
address them in terms that debunked the
gender.
Binary world has guilty of a hate crime
punishable by imposable fines.
How about six months ago,
I wrote a column in this space about the
acceptance by the Supreme Court of
Canada to hear an appeal of judgments
from well-reasoned local courts or
request from a British Columbia band of
native people,
numbering 900 who claimed that 25 years
of consultation was constitutionally
inadequate over a proposed ski area that
an elder of their band was super
naturally advised and after a lapse of
some years told his people would drive
off the spirit of the grizzly bear that
was central to the religion of that
band.
I concluded the column with the shabby
polemical device that I only rarely
employed a rhetorical question in this
case.
Are we all mad?
Of course we are not and we still live
in a country where people can self
identify as they wish,
even if it diverges from apparent
realities,
but we're almost at the point where
people who declined to be legally forced
to acknowledge the warning,
plausible applications of this right are
subject to persecution by social justice
warriors and quite conceivably the
government.
We're not almost at that point,
Mr Black,
it's already written into law.
We're terribly finally reluctant to
impose normal rules,
free discourse over the agitation of
people who are using an imagined
unlimited latitude on sexual self
description to gag,
dictate to and prosecute reasonable
people exercising their rights to free
expression.
It is another manifestation
parentheses of which the hyper
hypocritically respectful limitations
about the Stalinists desk bought Fidel
Castro or another and parentheses of
what my late friend Malcolm muggeridge
called the great liberal death wish.
The great majority do not want to go
along for that ride.
And this time the great majority must be
heard and obeyed.
All right,
so I told you what I thought about Mr
Black's comments and uh,
and now I'm going to read a legal
opinion about them.
Uh,
Mr. Block,
I regularly read your articles with
interest.
I have interest in many of the subjects
that you seem to devote attention to
including US history in presidential
politics and behavior.
I have further enjoyed your recent
appearances on CNN with respect,
respect to the trump phenomenon.
I was motivated to write to you in this
instance with respect to your article in
the National Post today mentioned in the
subject line of this email,
a right not to detract from your main
thesis regarding Mr Peterson and those
aligned against him,
but rather to identify potentially ms
dot point of importance.
In your article,
you call into question the volume of Mr
Peterson's rhetoric.
My words not yours as being
disproportionate by identifying that
imprisonment is not the punishment that
he faces by disregarding the gender
neutral ideology and any resultant
orders from a human rights tribunal.
While you may be and hopefully are
correct that in prison,
it meant is not a Mr Peterson's future.
The path to prison remains clear.
The key point being that the human
rights tribunals can and regularly do
order nonmonetary remedies in addition
to the typical and well known monetary
awards well,
failure to pay a financial penalty can
result in imprisonment.
It is admittedly a long and winding road
not entirely related to the unpaid
penalty itself.
That being said,
if a tribunal war to issue its standard
order,
it wouldn't necessarily include some
variation of the following.
Number one,
a declaratory order requiring Mr
Peterson not to misgender someone again
or use the wrong pronouns.
Number two,
a gag order requiring him to refrain
from discussing the subject in public
possible given his academic status.
Number three,
a publication ban requiring him to
refrain from publishing on these
subjects possible given his media
presence and number four,
to take mandatory sensitivity or anti
bias training if Mr Peterson were to
breach these orders.
For example,
by refusing to participate in the
training and guess what I would do?
The typical recourse of the tribunal is
to pursue a contempt of court which
inevitably results in prison.
Section 19 of the Statutory Powers
Procedures Act,
Ontario states that an order of the
tribunal is an order of the superior
court.
Section 13 of the statutory powers
Procedures Act says the tribunal can
pursue a breach of its own order by
bringing an application to the
divisional court superior court on that
application.
The divisional court employees rule 60
point one,
one of the rules of civil procedure
which states that when faced with
contempt of a nonmonetary order of the
Superior Court,
the court can order imprisonment for an
indefinite period and finds the civil
courts send people to prison for
breaches of nonmonetary injunctions,
non defamation orders with some
regularity.
Furthermore,
human rights tribunals have a history of
imprisoning persons for breaches of non
monetary and monetary tribunal orders.
This happened most notoriously under the
recently repealed section 13 hate speech
provisions of the Canadian Human Rights
Code,
of which Mr Lavato and Mr Stein quietly
performed Yulman service for all
Canadian citizens and having repealed.
While the likelihood of prison remains
highly contingent and remote,
it doesn't depend to a great extent on
the benevolence of the public servants
that staff,
the tribunal and the courts keep up the
good work d dot jared brown,
lead counsel,
deed,
Jared Brown,
Professional Corporation,
Toronto,
Ontario,
www dot brown,
law dot,
ca.
Well,
so there you have it.
That's the pathway to imprisonment for
failure to use the proper pronouns.
And so let's not be confusing absurdity
with triviality and I appreciate your
support,
Mr Black,
but I'm,
I'm afraid that you're treating the
issue in some regard as if it's.
If it as as at least elements of it are
beneath contempt and then it's being
blowing blown out of proportion and I'd
like to say as clearly as I possibly
can,
this is not being blown out of
proportion.
This is the state of current state of
Canadian law.